Le parc du Zhangjiajie, un jardin céleste
situé dans la province du Hunan,
dans le Sud-Est de la Chine.
Une fabuleuse forêt de pierres
suspendue entre ciel et terre,
méconnue par les Chinois eux-mêmes
jusque dans les années 70.
Des paysages vertigineux,
qui n'ont pas échappé à l'œil
du réalisateur James Cameron,
avec son film, Avatar.
L'original de son décor,
c'est ici qu'il est venu le chercher.
La planète Pandora est donc née au cœur
de ces pics rocheux émergeant de gouffres.
On les surnomme les premières
montagnes étranges de Chine.
Les amis, venez admirez notre échelle
céleste dite des 100 dragons !
Mehi Chenchen travaille
depuis plus de 20 ans dans ce parc.
Il est guide et emmène chaque jour
les touristes découvrir ces secrets.
Et ils sont nombreux. Ce parc naturel
s'étend sur 262 kilomètres carrés,
deux fois et demi la taille
d'une ville comme Paris.
Selon les géologues, il faut
remonter à 380 millions d'années.
À l'époque, ce n'était
qu'une vaste étendue d'eau.
Ensuite, il y a eu
des mouvements géologiques,
et l'eau a commencé à sculpter le massif.
Lorsque la mer s'est retirée,
les sommets se sont surélevés.
C'est pourquoi nous avons à Zhangjiajie,
3000 pics et plus de 800 ruisseaux.
L'endroit où nous nous trouvons fait
partie des 10 plus beaux paysages du parc.
On l'appelle le plateau des généraux,
car il y a 48 rochers qui s'élancent
droit comme des généraux.
Une topographie unique au monde,
avec ces 3000 pics qui fendent le ciel.
Très difficile d'accès,
l'endroit est resté isolé de la présence
humaine pendant des siècles.
Mais en Chine, le temps n'a pas
de prise sur les légendes.
Et chaque pic renferme son histoire.
Une histoire qui a pétri
l'imagination de tout un peuple.
Parfois leurs formes sont étranges.
C'est pourquoi chez nous,
les gens de la montagne,
quand on aperçoit un pic qui ressemble
à un animal ou à une plante,
on lui donne un nom correspondant.
Le pic du pinceau impérial
devant nous, par exemple.
Sa forme ressemble à celle
du pinceau impérial que le prince Xian,
qui s'est proclamé le Fils du ciel,
a utilisé pour commenter
les documents officiels.
Nous avons le plus grand respect
pour ce chef des rebelles.
Un autre exemple, ce pic, c'est celui
de la déesse qui disperse les fleurs.
Dans notre imaginaire, c'est comme une femme
élégante qui marche dans la montagne,
en portant dans ses deux mains
une corbeille de fleurs fraîches,
qu'elle disperse sur notre monde ici bas.
Donc, on peut dire qu'il y a un tiers de
ressemblances et deux tiers d'imagination.
Dans notre cœur, nous les locaux,
cette montagne occupe
une très grande place,
sans doute la plus sublime,
la plus noble.
Elle est un peu comme notre père,
quelqu'un qui nous protège.
C'est un patrimoine que nos ancêtres
nous ont laissé.
Un univers modelé par des mythes
que les touristes veulent capturer.
Ils étaient 40 millions en 2014,
surtout chinois,
à se bousculer au portillon.
Un parc naturel devenu parc d'attraction.
Et tout le monde veut sa part du rêve.
Alors en Chine,
on leur en donne l'impression.
Un téléphérique, le plus long du monde.
Le pont version made in China
et ses amours cadenassés par millions.
Un ascenseur greffé aux rochers,
l'un des plus hauts du monde.
326 mètres, on l'appelle ici
l'échelle céleste des 100 dragons.
Et depuis la sortie
du blockbuster américain,
tous veulent toucher du bout
de leur objectif, le pic Avatar.
J'ai vu le film Avatar, c'est vraiment
un film qui se distingue des autres.
J'ai été complètement fasciné.
L'autre sensation que j'ai ressenti quand le
réalisateur américain James Cameron,
a filmé notre montagne Zhangjiajie,
il a montré un parc
mystérieux, magnifique.
L'excellence du film m'a donné
une sensation difficile à nommer.
Comme si j'étais porté par le vent.
Un pilier devenu mondialement connu,
rebaptisé pour la circonstance hollywoodienne,
et qui a de fait un peu perdu
de son histoire originelle.
Avant, on l'appelait
la colonne du ciel et de la Terre.
Il est un peu comme
les hommes qui vivent ici.
C'est un sommet debout sur la terre,
et qui porte le ciel sur sa tête.
Chez nous, dans notre montagne,
la colonne du ciel et de la terre est un pic,
sur lequel on peut s'appuyer.
C'est comme un homme de chez nous,
donc on le considère comme quelqu'un
de la génération de nos pères.
Il est droit et cela symbolise le caractère
sans peur et sans reproche, comme nous,
les hommes de la montagne.
Le parc est classé au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO depuis 1992.
C'est l'un des dix
plus beaux parcs au monde.
Mais devant le flot
ininterrompu de touristes,
de constructions illégales,
de boutiques sauvages,
l'UNESCO a tiré la sonnette d'alarme
dans les années 2000.
Résultat,
après 420 millionsd'euros investis,
tout est aujourd'hui
canalisé, contingenté,
plus maîtrisé, faisant perdre un peu
de son caractère sauvage au site.
Regarde celui-là, il ressemble à un habit
de servante de l'ancien temps.
Mais celui-là est bien aussi.
Ici, on vient se gorger
de culture traditionnelle,
en cinq minutes chrono.
Le temps d'une pause
et il faut enchaîner.
Ce n'est pas ici que l'on va comprendre,
ce qui fait le charme
de ces costumes si singuliers.
Pour cela, il faut s'échapper
à plus de 200 km,
et se rendre dans le sud du Hunan.
Fènghuáng, la petite Venise de Chine.
En chinois, Fènghuáng signifie phénix.
D'après la légende, deux Phénix
ont un jour découvert la ville,
et l'ont trouvée si belle
qu'ils ne voulaient plus la quitter.
C'est aussi le berceau des Miao,
une des 56 ethnies minoritaires
de l'Empire du Milieu.
Ils sont aujourd'hui 9 millions, répartis
essentiellement dans le Sud-Est du pays.
C'est là que s'est installée Lang Yin,
et sa petite boutique à ciel ouvert.
Si je vous fais mal dites-moi !
Est-ce que ça va ?
Vous êtes jolie, il faut
trouver un joli bijou !
Vous savez, tout cela a été brodé
par les vieux du village.
C'est entièrement fait à la main.
Je suis une fille Miao.
Si je vends des choses ici, c'est pour
que les visiteurs connaissent notre culture.
Par exemple, ce bracelet est fait
de broderie et d'argent,
la broderie est entièrement
faite à la main.
Regardez, il y a une multitude
de couleurs et de motifs.
On s'inspire de belles choses telles
que les fleurs afin de broder ces motifs.
Ces bijoux en argent ont beaucoup
de signification chez nous.
Si après les avoir porté
longtemps ils noircissent,
c'est un signe de mauvaise santé.
Si vous êtes en bonne santé,
il brille de plus en plus.
Mais dans quelques jours, un événement
important va venir ponctuer son quotidien.
L'occasion pour elle
de retourner au village.
Je vais rentrer pour préparer mes affaires.
Il y a bientôt une fête,
le huitième jour du quatrième mois
de notre calendrier lunaire.
C'est une fête pour honorer nos ancêtres.
Je dois donc rentrer dans ma famille
pour préparer mes vêtements traditionnels.
Cette fête est aussi appelée
la fête de la danse des fleurs.
Mais elle porte plein d'autres noms.
La fête du culte des ancêtres,
la fête des chants improvisés.
C'est une fête très importante
chez nous, les Miao.
Il y a 4600 ans, les ancêtres des Miao,
se sont établis le long du fleuve Jaune.
Mais face à l'expansion du peuple Han,
les Miao ont été forcés d'immigrer,
vers le sud du pays.
Le roi Chiyou a été tué pendant la guerre,
et lui rendent régulièrement hommage.
Les Miao, un peuple de la montagne,
qui raffole de chants
et de danses traditionnelles.
Des fêtes qui viennent
alléger une vie de labeur.
Après 1h de route,
Lang Yin arrive à Ma'anshan,
le village où vit sa grande tante.
- Bonjour ma tante !
- Te voilà !
- Ça va, les affaires ?
- Oui, ça va.
À 21 ans, si Lang Yin a succombé
aux tumultes de la ville,
elle aime revenir ici et s'enrichir
du savoir faire de ses aînés.
Une manière pour elle de perpétuer
la tradition de tout un peuple.
Ça fait longtemps
que tu fais des vêtements ?
J'ai commencé quand j'avais
une dizaine d'années.
Combien de temps tu mets
pour faire un vêtement ?
- Pour une veste, une semaine.
- Une semaine...
Aujourd'hui, il y a de moins en moins de
personnes qui fabriquent des vêtements Miao.
Nous, les anciennes, nous avançons en âge,
et nous voulons apprendre aux jeunes
pour qu'eux-mêmes transmettent aux autres.
Quand l'ancienne génération s'efface,
la nouvelle doit prendre le relais.
De moins en moins de personnes
savent faire des costumes,
et les expliquer aux autres.
L'essentiel des vêtements
est fait à la main.
Alors, avec le festival
qui a lieu dans six jours,
pas un instant à perdre.
- T'as fini ?
- Presque.
Aujourd'hui il va falloir travailler dur,
car il ne reste que quelques jours
avant le festival, tu sais.
Même s'il faut se précipiter,
le temps ici s'écoule à un rythme
bien différent de celui de Zhangjiajie.
Retour à Zhangjiajie.
Au pied des pics de pierre,
une rivière a dessiné son lit.
Jinbianxi.
La rivière du fouet d'or.
C'est là que Mehi Chenchen nous conduit.
Le parc est un sanctuaire providentiel
pour de nombreuses espèces animales.
Certaines en voie de disparition,
comme la salamandre géante de Chine.
C'est le plus grand
amphibien vivant au monde.
D'autres, beaucoup moins farouches.
Les singes rhésus très présents
dans le sud de l'Asie.
Ils sont plusieurs milliers dans le parc.
La nourriture y est abondante.
Mehi Chenchen les connaît bien.
Il les côtoie depuis son enfance.
Quand un petit veut sortir
de son groupe, il fait...
Quand un grand doit
faire face à une agression,
il rassemble ses congénères.
Ensemble, ils vont montrer
leur férocité en faisant...
Quand vous leur donnez à manger,
il faut bien connaître leurs habitudes.
Il ne faut surtout pas vous accroupir,
car le singe va penser
que vous voulez l'attaquer.
Il va appeler sa famille
et son groupe à la charge.
Malheur à vous à ce moment là,
vous risquez d'être blessé.
Une proximité avec ces animaux,
qui lui a permis d'assister
à des scènes quelquefois insolites.
Il y a dix ans,
j'ai vu de mes yeux un événement.
Des singes voulaient migrer
et passer d'un pic à un autre.
Ils devaient se battre comme chez
nous quand on se fait la guerre.
Alors les singes ont franchi la frontière
et se sont retrouvés en territoire ennemi.
Le combat a eu lieu et ils ont vaincu.
Des singes du territoire
soumis ont été blessés.
L'un d'entre eux a même trouvé la mort.
À ce moment là, les troupeaux autrefois
rivaux se sont rassemblés,
et ils ont organisé des obsèques
pour leurs défunts.
Chez nous les hommes s'habillent
en blanc lors d'un deuil.
Les macaques prennent les feuilles
d'une plante qu'ils mettent sur la tête.
Ces feuilles ont un côté blanc, ce qui m'a
donné l'impression qu'ils étaient en deuil.
Ensuite, ils ont creusé un trou
pour enterrer leur défunt,
et ont laissé sa queue
dépasser à l'extérieur.
Un membre du groupe est resté
à le veiller tous les jours.
Ils ont finalement
dit adieu à ce macaque,
avant leur départ définitif
vers un autre pic.
Pour moi, ces animaux
sont vraiment intelligents.
Et sur les bords de cette rivière,
on peut découvrir également
des plantes uniques,
et méconnues sous nos latitudes.
Une pharmacopée géante.
Seuls les gens d'ici
en connaissent le pouvoir.
Mais la montagne renferme aussi ses
guérisseurs aux visages de pierre.
La montagne pour moi,
c'est mon protecteur, le dieu montagne.
Tous les jours, nous habitons
dans cette grande montagne humide.
Elle est belle comme dans un tableau.
Nous en sommes fiers et contents.
Par exemple, le pic du vieillard
qui cueille les herbes médicinales,
dans notre cœur,
il est à la fois divinité et médecin.
Si nous sommes atteints d'un quelconque
malaise ou d'une maladie,
nous avons l'habitude de former discrètement
un vœu en suppliant le dieu montagne.
Alors on sait que le vieillard qui cueille
les herbes médicinales va nous guérir.
Nous habitons dans la montagne,
nous respirons l'air frais.
Nous pensons ainsi devenir des immortels.
C'est pourquoi nous devons aimer et protéger
notre montagne, notre Dieu pour l'éternité.
Chez les Miao, c'est jour de marché.
Un moment incontournable pour les villageois,
qui viennent des quatre coins de la montagne
pour vendre leur petite production.
Un marché qui se trouve à deux pas du village
de Lang Yin.
Sa mère l'accompagne.
Il ne reste plus que cinq jours
avant le festival Miao.
Au milieu de ce feu d'artifice de couleurs,
elles sont venues chercher les éléments
du costume qui leur manque encore.
Je cherche de la couleur.
Vous avez d'autres couleurs ?
Oui, il y a celle-ci, celle-là...
Regarde comme c'est beau !
Oui, ce n'est pas le même.
Allonge ton bras pour voir.
Je suis en train d'essayer
différentes couleurs,
et voir celles qui me conviendront le mieux,
pour que mes vêtements sautent
aux yeux quand je les porterais.
La légende prétend que les Miao
auraient perdu leur écriture.
Leurs costumes sont ainsi devenu
au fil du temps un langage,
un mode d'expression de leur culture.
Ça, c'est un canard mandarin.
Pour les femmes mariées ou fiancées,
on met deux canards sur le vêtement.
Moi, je ne suis pas encore amoureuse d'un
garçon, je ne suis pas encore mariée,
alors je vais choisir
un vêtement avec un seul canard.
Et pour sa couleur, je veux qu'elle soit
éclatante, très belle, très jolie.
Dragon, Canard, Fleur,
autant de symbole d'amour
ou de bon augure.
Un art que même Mao Zedong
n'a pas pu effacer.
Pourtant, aujourd'hui, ce savoir faire
est en train de disparaître.
Ces fleurs là, il faut les broder
les unes sur les autres.
Ça prend quinze jours.
Pour ce ruban, il faut encore
cinq jours pour le broder.
On le brode aussi nous même.
Pour finir un costume,
il faut compter en tout un mois.
C'est difficile de faire ces costumes.
Les gens ne gagnent pas vraiment d'argent avec.
Alors maintenant, les jeunes préfèrent
travailler ailleurs pour s'enrichir.
C'est comme ça !
Moi, j'aime beaucoup ces costumes,
et c'est grâce à l'influence
des gens de mon village.
C'est vrai, c'est relativement compliqué,
mais je suis motivée.
Pour les faire, il faut apprendre
les techniques et ça prend du temps.
Tel que la broderie.
C'est très compliqué et on ne gagne
pas beaucoup d'argent.
Mais ça m'est égal.
J'aime les choses de mon peuple.
Des techniques comme venue d'un autre âge.
Cet après-midi, les femmes du village ont
sorti leur drôle de machine à broder les rubans.
Des fils de soie qu'elles tissent
avec la dextérité d'un jongleur,
malgré leur main parcheminée.
Lang Yin, elle,
s'y perd un peu quelques fois.
Grand-mère,
je me suis trompée je pense...
Regarde-moi faire.
Tu fais d'abord un tour comme ça,
puis comme ça...
D'accord. Et après j'accroche ça où ?
Je vois qu'elles travaillent très vite.
Et en plus les motifs qu'elles font
sont bien plus beaux que les miens.
Moi, j'aime beaucoup être à leurs côtés.
Elles partagent leur expérience avec moi,
et quelquefois les détails
de leur rencontre amoureuse.
Des heures de travail
pour quelques centimètres de rubans.
Un détail sur le costume,
mais il a son importance.
Ce motif entre les deux rubans,
par exemple, ressemble à un dragon.
Sa forme y fait penser.
Il se développe en courbes,
ce qui signifie la paix.
On manifeste ainsi le prestige
de notre statut social.
Nous les Miao, nous sommes
tous les descendants du dragon,
qui est un de nos ancêtres.
Des savoir faire qui, malgré
la volonté de Lang Yin de les préserver,
s'étiolent doucement.
Pour dénicher Monsieur Yuh,
il a fallu faire des kilomètres.
C'est le dernier teinturier de la région.
Un métier dur qu'il fait
depuis son plus jeune âge.
Il a aujourd'hui 70 ans.
Dans ses réserves, un bien précieux.
L'indigo, une couleur essentielle
chez les Miao du Hunan.
Avant, cette teinture était obtenue
à partir d'une herbes de chez nous.
Mais aujourd'hui avec la modernisation,
on l'obtient par la chimie.
Dans notre minorité, nous aimons
tous nous habiller en indigo.
On a des chapeaux indigo,
des vestes indigo, des pantalons indigo.
Nous arpentons la montagne
tous les jours et c'est fatigant.
Si vous vous habillez en foncé,
ça vous protège de la lumière du soleil.
Chez nous, c'est une coutume.
Et dans leur tradition vestimentaire,
un motif revient souvent.
Il va naître sous les doigts de sa femme.
Après avoir plié,
cousu très fort le tissu,
Monsieur Yuh le plonge
dans son bain de couleur.
Pendant des heures,
il va le faire danser à bout de bras,
pour qu'enfin le motif apparaisse.
C'est celui du mythe fondateur
de leur culture.
C'est un papillon.
Il a deux ailes.
Ça, ce sont ses antennes.
C'est en mémoire à notre minorité.
Nous avons été déposés sur ce monde
par notre maman papillon.
Donc, dans notre peuple
nous commémorons tous la mère Papillon.
Ensuite, je porte le tissu sur la tête.
Si je le porte ainsi,
c'est pour que la mère Papillon
me protège toute la vie.
Un processus long et fastidieux
qui se moque du passage du temps.
Mais ce métier d'alchimiste
de la couleur,
a également du mal à séduire
les jeunes générations.
Ça, ça ne les intéresse pas.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ce travail est sale et ingrat.
On gagne pas beaucoup d'argent,
donc ce métier va disparaître
avec la modernité.
C'est irrémédiable !
On ne peut pas le sauver.
C'est pourquoi aucun jeune
ne s'y intéresse.
Quand j'en ai parlé avec les jeunes,
avec mes enfants,
ils n'étaient pas d'accord
pour reprendre le métier.
Ils m'ont dit : "Ta technique
va disparaître. Le monde a évolué."
Au parc de Zhangjiajie,
Mehi Chenchen, notre guide,
nous attire cette fois
dans les méandres de la terre.
La grotte du Dragon jaune,
une des plus anciennes grottes de Chine.
Plus de onze kilomètres de long.
140 mètres de haut,
une sorte de vertige inversé.
Un décor à la chinoise acidulé à souhait,
qui laisse place une fois de plus
à une légende.
Elle raconte qu'il y a bien longtemps,
un maître taoïste a osé pénétrer
dans l'antre du dragon.
Autrefois, à Zhangjiajie,
un maître taoïste voulait soulager le peuple
de la sécheresse qui frappait localement.
Afin d'obtenir un peu de pluie,
il est arrivé dans cette grotte,
avec son couteau de commandeur
et a supplié le roi Dragon.
Le roi Dragon lui a alors donné une
goutte d'eau dans sa coupe d'argent.
Mais le maître à penser
que c'était trop peu.
Alors il a voulu le menacer avec son
couteau afin qu'il lui donne plus d'eau.
À ce moment là,
le roi Dragon s'est mis en colère.
Il a renversé un bassin rempli d'eau,
ce qui a déclenché un déluge de 7 jours,
à l'extérieur de la grotte.
L'eau a alors submergé le maître taoïste
et il s'est transformé en petit canard,
qui a rejoint le monde extérieur à la nage.
L'eau a envahi tout le village
et s'est retrouvée ici.
C'est l'origine de la source
de la grotte du Dragon jaune.
Mais notre guide est préoccupé.
Depuis sa découverte en 1983,
la grotte attire tous les regards.
Ceux des scientifiques d'abord.
Plus de 70 se sont penchés sur ces dépôts de
calcite et ses arabesques de pierres millénaires.
Mais ce sont les visiteurs,
toujours plus nombreux,
qui risquent pour Mehi Chenchen,
de fragiliser ce décor minéral.
Dans mon cœur, je pense surtout
à notre grotte du dragon jaune.
C'est la plus belle parmi les 40 grottes
dans la région de Zhangjiajie.
Et même de tout l'ouest du Hunan.
C'est reliefs en forme de ruines,
ces stalagmites, ces colonnes en pierre,
sont bien plus nombreuses qu'ailleurs.
En même temps, les touristes
qui entrent ici sont trop nombreux.
Cela entraîne une pollution de l'air
à l'intérieur qui est extrêmement grave.
Les reliefs de calcaire et les colonnes
de pierre ont changé de couleur.
Ils se sont noircis.
Nous devons donc nous mobiliser afin de
trouver des solutions pour bien les protéger,
et les garder sain et sauf.
Après les profondeurs,
nous partons tutoyer les sommets.
Loin des sentiers battus,
là où très peu de touristes s'aventurent
Mehi Chenchen nous emmène
dans un lieu qui défie la gravité.
Le village de Cong Jong Tiên Yuan.
Son nom signifie rizière
suspendue dans le vide.
Ici ce n'est pas le peuple des Na'vis
d'Avatar,
que l'on croise sur ce pic
en forme de toit terrasse,
Mais les Tujias,
une ethnie de paysans et d'éleveurs
la plus nombreuse dans le parc.
Mehi Chenchen les connais bien.
Il est lui même Tujia.
Un jardin suspendu, entièrement façonné
à la sueur de cet homme Puen Chiyung.
Salut, comment ça va ?
- Encore en train de labourer.
- Oui.
C'est du maïs ça non ?
Moi, j'ai commencé à travailler à l'âge
de 15 ans, quand j'étais encore adolescent.
à 23 ans, en 1983, je suis venu
sur ce champ pour le cultiver.
Il est alimenté par toute cette eau grâce
à laquelle j'ai pu travailler la terre.
Et ça m'a pris cinq ans pour que ce champ
devienne ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui.
Sarrasin, pommes de terre, maïs, riz.
L'essentiel y est, et même plus encore.
Je suis un paysan Tujia.
Je vis du fruit de mon travail.
On est tranquille dans la montagne !
On vit de notre culture, des porcs,
des chèvres qu'on élève.
Vivre dans la montagne,
c'est vraiment agréable pour nous.
Mais la beauté de la montagne
ne suffit pas.
Ce mode de vie est rude.
Comme chez les Miao, il a du mal
à séduire la nouvelle génération.
Nos jeunes ont envie d'aller en ville
et on ne peut pas les obliger à rester.
Ils sont jeunes,
ils n'ont jamais vraiment souffert.
Ils ne comprennent pas encore qu'il leur
faut aimer tout ce qui les entoure.
Ils ne pensent qu'au plaisir de la ville.
Des villes animées dans lesquelles
ils seront heureux, où ils vont s'amuser,
auront le cœur léger.
Mais une fois qu'ils auront atteint
notre âge, la quarantaine,
ils vont s'apercevoir
de la beauté de cette montagne.
L'air y est 100 fois,
1000 fois, 10 000 fois meilleur,
que n'importe quel endroit en ville.
Donc quand ils auront notre âge,
ils vont, j'en suis sûr,
revenir sur cette terre
où nous nous trouvons.
C'est pourquoi je ne
m'inquiète pas du tout.
Il nous suffit de faire plus d'efforts,
et de bien préserver cette terre
afin de leur laisser un bel héritage.
À quelques jours du festival Miao,
Monsieur Long Tithan travaille sans répit.
Il est bijoutier et chez les Miao,
les parures constituent de véritables
ornements pour les jeunes filles.
Des parures en argent pour la plupart,
un matériau devenu noble pour ce peuple.
Chez nous, les Miao, on est pauvre,
on ne peut pas acheter de l'or.
Mais on peut acheter de l'argent.
Un gramme d'or vaut 500 grammes d'argent.
S'il s'agit d'un mariage,
on peut acheter un peu d'or,
si les gens le demandent.
Avant, quand on épousait une femme,
un kilo d'argent suffisait.
Mais aujourd'hui,
il faut cinq kilos d'argent.
La société a changé
et notre vie s'est améliorée.
Avant, on n'aurait pas pu
s'acheter de l'argent,
car l'essentiel était consacré
à la nourriture.
Un travail d'orfèvre,
des gestes 1000 fois répétés,
pour sculpter des motifs qui puisent
leur origine dans l'histoire des Miao.
Des formes dont M. Long Tithan
a d'ailleurs complètement oublié le sens.
Son assistant, lui,
en connaît un peu le secret.
Chez nous les Miao,
afin de respecter la tradition,
les jeunes filles
doivent porter ce collier,
sinon elles ne pourront pas se marier.
C'est comme ça.
Là au milieu, c'est une grande fleur.
Elle représente le rôle central
de la femme.
Celui-ci est un motif
en forme de corne de buffle,
le même buffle, symbole de Chiyou,
notre ancêtre.
Ici, cela représente un arbre,
au moment de la floraison,
quand les fleurs vont éclore.
Ce motif représente
une colonne de balance.
Il signifie que tout
se déroule selon nos souhaits.
Celle-ci est une fleur de péché.
Elle représente le cœur,
le sentiment amoureux de la femme.
Et là, pour terminer,
c'est la queue du dragon.
Des ornements qui restent essentiels
pour les jeunes filles.
Plus elles en sont parées,
plus elles seront courtisées.
Le savoir faire de Monsieur Long Tithan
n'est pour l'instant pas prêt de s'éteindre.
Ce matin il pleut sur Ma'anshan,
le village de Lang Yin.
L'occasion d'oublier un peu
le travail des champs,
pour préparer le festival qui s'approche.
C'est l'heure de la répétition
pour le groupe de Lang Yin.
Toutes les filles ont revêtu leur costume
pour régler les derniers détails.
Les Miao excellent
également par la danse,
dans l'art d'exprimer leurs histoires
et leurs sentiments intimes.
Et c'est madame Yoshi Fung
qui donne le ton.
Lors de ce festival, les jeunes hommes
et les jeunes filles,
vont tous être vêtus
dans leur joli costume Miao.
Et quand ils vont se rencontrer,
ils vont être très contents,
et pourront alors livrer
leurs sentiments en toute liberté.
Lang Yin répète la danse aux fleurs.
Une danse de séduction traditionnelle
où le moindre geste compte.
Ce geste, par exemple, c'est pour dire qu'on
est très content et qu'on est très ouverts.
Il y a aussi des mouvements
qui vous souhaite la bienvenue.
Et d'autres que l'on puise
dans la réalité du quotidien.
On danse aussi main dans la main
avec le garçon,
comme si on s'amusait en se promenant.
Ce mouvement est vraiment caractéristique
de notre folklore.
En général, quand nous
rencontrons des jeunes garçons,
et que cela nous fait
plaisir de les voir,
nous faisons ce mouvement.
C'est un geste vraiment indispensable
dans nos danses, chez nous, les Miao.
Et Madame Yoshi Fung se souvient.
C'est comme ça qu'elle a rencontré
son mari il y a 30 ans.
À l'époque, j'avais aperçu un beau garçon,
et au retour de la fête de la danse
aux fleurs, il nous a suivi.
Il m'a tapé sur l'épaule.
J'ai tourné la tête pour regarder,
comme ça.
J'ai vu que je lui plaisais alors
je lui ai fait comprendre que moi aussi.
Et ensuite, nous avons commencé
à nous fréquenter.
Pour Lang Yin, ce festival sera peut-être
l'occasion de faire une belle rencontre.
Pour l'instant, je n'ai pas
rencontré de garçon qui me plaise.
Mais si j'ai du succès au festival,
alors je serai contente.
Loin des touristes
et de leurs crépitement intempestifs,
Mehi Chenchen nous fait découvrir
un endroit connu de lui seul.
Son petit ermitage
aux cloisons invisibles.
Pour moi les touristes
ce n'est pas un problème.
Parce que la beauté naturelle de Zhangjiajie,
si je la garde pour moi-même,
alors je suis un égoïste.
Je veux que le monde entier
vienne profiter de cette nature.
Quant aux dégradations liées
aux touristes, c'est difficile à éviter.
Nous sommes tous différents.
Alors je dois faire de mon mieux
pour protéger ce parc,
pour le garder sain et sauf,
pour bien préserver son écologie.
Et je suis prêt à tout faire
pour mieux maîtriser leurs impacts.
Ce paysage mérite l'admiration de tous.
Je me dois de le transmettre
à mes enfants, à mes petits enfants,
et aux générations à venir.
Veille du festival
sur la montagne de Bagong,
entre brume et brouillard.
Lang Yin est là, comme de nombreux
villageois, pour venir assister,
à une cérémonie peu ordinaire.
Les Miao pratiquent le chamanisme.
Sur ce promontoire naturel,
les chamanes convoquent tous les esprits,
pour que le festival se déroule
sous les meilleurs auspices.
L'endroit où nous sommes,
c'est la montagne Bagong.
C'est un endroit important
pour rendre un culte à nos ancêtres.
Nous avons quatre pics.
Ici pour le ciel, là pour les hommes.
Là-bas pour la terre
et enfin la roche des filles.
Nous rendons grâce à nos ancêtres,
le roi Chiyou en particulier.
C'est très important pour nous les Miao.
Beaucoup de Miao d'autres régions
viennent voir également notre cérémonie.
Elle est importante pour moi aussi.
Alcool de riz, viande de bœuf, de porc,
autant d'offrandes pour séduire les dieux.
On pense également aux disparus
en laissant partir en fumée,
ces petits bouts de papier jaune perforé.
Au sommet, les tambours prennent le relais.
Il faut déranger les dieux pour
qu'ils viennent protéger les habitants.
Des danses presque tribales pour rappeler
que le festival est aussi celui de la vie.
Nous venons de jouer le tambour
de la danse des singes,
une danse typique de chez nous.
On imite les singes à la recherche
de leur femme ou de jolies filles.
Après 5h de prières,
les galets en bois des chamanes
viennent de parler.
Leur face opposée est un signe.
Les dieux viennent d'accorder
leur bénédiction.
C'est le grand jour du festival.
Ce jour tant attendu.
Lang Yin vient tout juste de terminer
son costume avec l'aide de sa mère,
et de sa grande tante.
Il a été entièrement conçu à la main
par ma mère et moi pour que je sois jolie.
Il sera mon costume du Festival
de la danse aux fleurs.
Et pour la circonstance,
son costume renferme en lui
d'autres symboles précieux,
une sorte de livre ouvert.
Sur ce vêtement,
on a deux couples de pie.
Cela signifie la réjouissance.
On a aussi un canard mandarin.
Ça, c'est une pivoine.
La pivoine,
c'est la fleur nationale de la Chine.
Elle est bien ouverte
et sa couleur est très éclatante.
Mais le costume ne serait rien
sans ces ornements.
Des bijoux conservés dans la famille
comme un trésor.
Chez nous, les Miao,
on porte des bijoux en argent.
Plus il y a de bijoux,
plus on est joli.
On attribue la valeur
du bijou à son poids.
Plus il est lourd, plus il est beau.
Mais vraiment, je ne peux en porter
que 3 car ils sont vraiment très lourds.
Ici, c'est un papillon forgé en argent.
C'est notre maman papillon.
Elle est importante pour nous les Miao.
Sur chaque costume, on la retrouve.
C'est très joli !
Ça doit être unique au monde.
Le festival vient de démarrer.
Il est 10h18 car en Chine,
le chiffre huit porte bonheur.
23 groupes venus de toute la province,
se sont donné rendez-vous
sur la place du village de Ma'anshan,
le village de Lang Yin.
La fête de la danse aux fleurs,
un festival où chacun
vient défendre ses couleurs.
Chaque groupe défile
au rythme de sa musique,
traditionnelle ou plutôt inattendue.
C'est au tour de Lang Yin
et de son groupe.
C'est important pour moi de contribuer
à l'expansion de la culture Miao.
Si nous parvenons à la transmettre,
alors les gens qui sont partis
en ville vont revenir vers elle.
Tout ce que j'ai appris vient
de ma grand-mère, de ma mère,
et je dois transmettre
ses connaissances aux autres,
qui eux-mêmes les transmettront.
Ainsi, l'influence
de la culture Miao va se répandre,
et elle va pouvoir continuer son chemin.
Lang Yin et Mehi Chenchen
sont convaincus,
de la force de leur culture
et de leurs traditions.
Leur optimisme saura-t-il résister
aux bouleversements de l'époque moderne,
qui secoue la Chine ?
Au cœur de ces montagnes,
révélées au monde par le film Avatar,
une nouvelle histoire reste à écrire.
Celle d'un peuple
à l'histoire millénaire.